here we are again another year another
completely lacking creative evolution no
hi my name is Gary Schutt no no you know
your life is different now I'm not a
person that's ever loved the holidays so
much that I feel a need to apologize or
defend myself for getting too excited
too early in the year there are people
that should love Halloween and people
that [ __ ] love Christmas can't we put
all those people in one locker room and
just see what happens
I've done this many times before I've
given you cheap dumb easy last minute
DIY Halloween costume ideas and this
year we've started again with cheap DIY
rapper inspired Halloween costume ideas
that these are sort of pun costumes
they're definitely fun costumes you can
basically make these at home or spend
very very minimal amounts of money on
items to make these very cringy but fun
DIY irreverence Baron Halloween costumes
you're gonna cringe you're gonna cringe
trigger warnings cringe and these
costumes are stupid but also Halloween
guys come on is really stupid in a good
way okay for this first one you bunch of
sweaters and then I just took a piece of
poster board I wrote the letter B on it
cardigan B and sweat away yeah I told
you they'd be cringe-worthy I gave you a
toy warden oh the next one you just need
some takeout bags from some of your
favorite restaurants to chains next one
stretch think you didn't already assume
that you'll get a great hoodie I know
there's so many people oh I know
then take your phone add some theatrics
and just kind of run in place at the
party and pretend you're texting someone
like you're gonna get to them as soon as
possible you can say out loud be there
as soon as possible I'll be there as
soon as possible
Aesop Rock e Balboa okay I think this
one we're going to need a name tag and a
gun-control protest sign machine gun
control
yeah for this one we need where a sign
of a state you recently went to and
we're delighted by how fun it was
without expectation that's an absolutely
real Gucci bag you have laying around
your house Gucci Mane mm-hmm this is not
good for this one you need a classic New
York Yankees hat that you've definitely
always owned and become your iconic
signature look and zzzquil jay-z will
they get worse take the sequel put
yourself to sleep for another video
happens oh sorry
kicked you right in your toe this one's
a fun easy one all you need is a tea bag
and some tape put it just like an
eyepatch TI oh wait I forgot you can
also for this one keep duarte and these
make sure you hold your stomach like you
have severe PMS all night t-pain's
throws really good they're both
incredible and you're welcome oh this
one's fun this one you can do two nights
in a row and like repurpose this guy you
need your name tag again slightly
repurposed and then your trusty cheese
biscuit eat that thing last one this one
you're gonna repurpose one of your most
prized possessions and then take an
eyeliner pencil and
fancy your face up a little bit and then
your post mates Malone you are better
now better now even though that my
subscribers are not around not around
well there you go there are my dumb
last-minute very cheap very DIY rapper
inspired Halloween costumes I hope this
inspired you if you have any ideas for
DIY pun dumb costumes leave them in the
comments down below
adora to subscribe to this youtube
channel if you like stagnant uninventive
dumb ideas that's the only thing I'm
consistent at hit that Bell
notifications so you know exactly when
they go up because that's the
inconsistent part of that add it up
honestly this is how we know that I'm
not a sociopath is that I am NOT
obsessed with gaining these subscribers
yes hey I'm losing them fast and haven't
changed the course oh that's the
definition of insanity right is doing
the same thing over and over again and
expecting a different outcome
so not a sociopath I'm just not
completely sane I probably bad